So a couple of years ago,
I went through a pretty brutal breakup,
and to keep myself distracted,
I decided to set myself
a ridiculous art challenge:
o create the closest thing
to a real-life time machine
with very little technical experience
and the bank account
of a college graduate.
Now, I know this sounds crazy,
but avoiding your feelings
is a very powerful force.
And I had a plan.
You see, all I had to do
was to spend an entire year
wearing 3D cameras on my face,
record my life
in first person for 365 days,
transfer that into a series of hard drives
and then build
a virtual reality simulation
that will let me experience
those memories in 3D.
That's all I had to do.
In other words, I was going to create
a personal time machine,
a virtual-reality invention
that will let me go back in time
and experience moments from my past.
And building this was pretty insane.
I had to learn a lot of technical skills
in a really short span of time,
and for an entire year,
my Tinder profile looked like this.
(Laughter)
But in the end, it was all worth it
because the final result
was so much cooler
than I could have ever imagined.
So this is how it works.
You put on a VR headset, you select a date
and time you’d like to go back to,
you pull a lever and then, bam.
I got to see exactly what I saw
at that given point in time.
And in this case, I was eating
a bagel in a tree,
which was the thing that I used to do.
And now I could go back in time
and re-experience a past trip,
try a meal again for the first time
and even hang out with a friend
who is no longer with us.
And the longer I spent
with this time machine,
the more I realized that I had
accidentally built something
that was much more meaningful
than I initially imagined.
Because this wasn't just an entirely new
way for you to experience your memories.
This was an entirely new way
for you to understand yourself.
As I used the time machine,
I started to become hyper aware
of how much of our lives we forget
over the years
and how important it is for us
to enjoy the moments we have
before our minds inevitably forget them.
I learned to be kinder to myself,
as watching myself wander
through life in third person
kind of taught me how much
of a dick I am to myself
when things get rough.
And I even started to have
an active friendship with myself,
as in many of my recordings,
you find me talking to future me,
sending thoughts, hopes
and feelings across time.
And this was really cool.
And it was also really confusing.
Because I was just trying
to get over my ex with some art.
But somehow by mixing art and technology,
we ended up in a really interesting place.
And the world agreed.
The time machine went super viral,
50 million people saw it,
and it even inspired people
to start entire companies
based off this concept.
So it seemed that by mixing art and tech,
I created something
innovative by accident.
And because that made me feel pretty good,
I was like, can we do that again?
Could I just take emerging technology,
you know, the stuff that's weird,
the stuff that we don't understand,
do some art and just
accidentally innovate?
And so our journey begins.
A couple of months go by,
and ladies and gentlemen,
I was back in the game.
I had a new girlfriend.
Her name was Max,
and things were going well,
and Valentine's Day
was just around the corner.
So me being me, I decided to gift her
a little bit of an art project.
So we're about to see is
what I can see from my perspective.
I'm wearing an AR headset
that's tracking her body in real time.
So here we go.
So love is a really abstract feeling.
It's something we all feel
but we can't see or hear.
So I created this experience
that turned the touch between two lovers
into this visual and auditory symphony,
basically transforming intimacy
into visuals and sounds,
which I thought was pretty cool.
And Max got to play me too,
which I think she liked.
But when I posted this online,
people started telling me that I had built
something completely different.
And that is when I realized
that by engaging in this artistic
exploration of intimacy,
I created a new kind
of musical instrument,
a particle synthesizer that lets you play
complex sounds in midair like this.
(Music)
Pretty cool, right?
(Applause)
Wait, we're not done.
Just for good measure,
I took those instruments,
and I attached them to a piece of clothing
so I could now play my own clothes
with my hand in mid-air,
which is ridiculous.
And I think it's the first example
of interactive digital musical fashion.
So for better or for worse,
art took us to some
really interesting ideas.
And at this point, I thought
I was onto something.
But then I had another breakup.
Audience: Aww.
LR: But it’s OK because an artist
can do what an artist does best,
which is to turn heartbreak into art.
So jokes aside, this was actually
a really difficult time in my life
because not only I was going through
all of that emotional turmoil,
I was also moving
to an entirely new country.
I was leaving my hometown from Brazil
and moving into the United States,
thousands of miles away from family,
no friends, didn't know anybody.
So it was probably the loneliest
I've been in my entire life.
So why not use this opportunity to take
my misery and make something cool?
What if we use VR
to create an experience
that's specifically designed
to foster the connection that I needed
to make me feel closer to strangers?
And that was the genesis
of "Where Thoughts Go."
So this is how it works.
You enter these virtual worlds
in which you're surrounded
by these sleeping creatures.
Each one of them is a voice message
left by another user
who was there before you were.
If you raise your fingers
and touch them gently,
you can listen to the voice messages
that people have left behind.
And in each one of these worlds,
you're asked a different
personal question.
So by playing this experience,
you're essentially going down
an intimacy funnel
in which you're getting to learn
about deeply intimate aspects
of other people's lives.
And of course, at the end
of each one of these worlds,
you can put your hands together,
give birth to your own little creature,
speak into it, and leave your messages
behind for others to find.
It was sweet, beautiful, anonymous.
And people would say things
in this experience
that they wouldn't share
with their closest friends.
And when I was making this,
everyone told me it was a horrible idea.
People would tell me
that trolls would destroy the entire app,
that people would be mean to each other,
they would make each other cry.
And you know what?
They weren't wrong.
(Laughter)
So when I started testing
"Where Thoughts Go"
with the first couple of hundred users,
I found out that roughly
20 percent of them
were crying at least once per session.
This is what I like to call
"Where Thoughts Go's" cry rate.
But people weren't crying
because they were being bullied.
People were crying because they were
feeling emotionally moved
by the messages of others.
We had created a system that instilled
a deep sense of empathy and connection
in a really short span of time.
And by making this, not only I was able
to get the connection that I was craving,
but I was able to give it
to others as well.
And because of how
this experience was designed,
there were virtually zero
trolls in the system.
It's like people
were walking into a church
and instinctively knew
to lower their voices,
treat each other respectfully
and treat the space
they were in as sacred,
which is a cool thing
you can only do in VR.
And when I put things that way,
it's clear that there's something
interesting here.
Some innovative ideas that could be used,
designs and lessons and approach
that could be applied
towards the entire internet.
But at this point,
you might go like, Lucas,
you're not really innovating anymore.
There's a lot of thought behind this.
And yes, but no, because a year
after I launched this,
medical doctors contacted me and told me
I invented a new form of group therapy.
And now this art piece
is being used in a medical trial
as an anxiety treatment tool.
And shortly after that,
I got to collaborate
with SpaceX and St Jude's
to make a version of this
that astronauts could use
so they could emotionally connect
with kids on Earth.
This is not what I was trying to do.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
But that's when it started to make sense.
And it's really simple.
When you take technology
that we don't understand
and you approach it as an artist,
you do things that the conventional
engineer would never think of doing.
And when you do that in a space brimming
with possibility, like emerging tech,
it's only a matter of time before you
stumble upon something of value.
That is why mixing art and tech
is a great way to accidentally innovate.
It takes you off the beaten path,
it removes creative constraints,
and it allows you to approach technology
in a way that's unique to you,
that leverages your passions
and your interests
and your life events and breakups.
And all of this just comes together
and gives you a unique angle of approach.
And that unique angle is everything.
Because here's the thing
about emerging technology,
and this applies to everything, VR, AI,
brain computers and whatever’s next.
No one knows what they're doing.
Everyone is just following blind hunches.
It's too early
in a technology's life cycle
for anyone to have a comprehensive view
of what it's good for.
And in a world where no one
knows what they're doing,
just following your gut
is a really great thing to do.
Because what we have here
is unlimited creative potential.
It's the ability to create
impossible objects out of thin air
at no carbon costs,
the ability to connect people
in ways never possible before.
And it's the ability to create technology
that changes how we look at ourselves
and the world around us.
We have all the tools we need
to create a future
that's beautiful and human and exciting.
And the only thing that threatens this
is if we have a massive
lapse of imagination.
So ...
Today I’m working on a new
project called “Pillow,”
and I'm trying to turn your bed,
the most comfortable place in your home,
into a mixed reality playground
of wellness, play and human connection.
And this is an early prototype,
but look how beautiful this is.
We're using mixed reality
to connect two beds together
and give people a way to engage
that's never been possible before.
And even though this is early,
there's so much that we're learning
about how to create meaningful connections
between people and virtual environments,
how to use artificial intelligence
to create immersive experiences
that really feel personal
and how to approach products
with accessibility in mind
from the get-go.
Things that work just as well
lying down on a couch
as they do in a hospital bed.
And I don't know where
this is going to go,
but it's going to be
somewhere interesting.
And when I look at this,
I just don't see art.
I see research.
I see things that could be turned
into products and companies.
And I want more artists
to start tech companies.
We need more artists in technology,
but we also just need more technologists
to think a little bit like artists.
Because some of the world's
most important ideas,
you really can't stumble upon them
by just trying to chase
the highest valuation.
Sometimes you only stumble upon them
when you approach technology
from a place of truth.
When you build things just
because you need to make them
and you don't know where you're going,
but if you follow your gut,
you will be rewarded.
And I don't know how or when,
like with anything else
that I told you about today,
but you will be rewarded.
We will all be rewarded.
And being true to yourself is just
a really good long-term strategy.
Technology gives us the tools,
but art shows us the way.
It's always been like this.
It's hard to find
a single futuristic startup
that hasn't been deeply inspired
by some kind of science fiction material.
Engineers have always followed
the imaginations of artists,
and that's not going
to change anytime soon.
But what is changing is that technology
is becoming easier to use.
I didn't know how to do
any of this five years ago.
Artists don't have to be
in the background anymore.
We can get our hands dirty
and build science nonfiction instead
to create projects and companies
that challenge the engineer-dominated
visions of technology
and propose something new,
something a little weirder
with a little more heart.
And I think in the process,
we can unlock new realities
that not only we are excited to live in,
but that we're excited to see
our children grow up in.
For the longest time in technology
artists imagine so engineers can build.
But I think engineers build,
so artists can imagine.
So if you have a crazy project
in your back pocket,
something you always wanted to do
but never got around to,
you should go for it.
You will never know what
you're going to find on the other side.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)